don't bring your kids to vegas it's not
for kids this ain't a kid's place no
it's not it's an adult playground you
are selfish when you are walking around
a casino with your six-year-old thinking
you're doing so you're there for you and
people are smoking there's also here
there's also [ __ ] everywhere there's
that which is why we go
am i right
[Music]
back off my broccolini
get your life together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
what's up you got a new dog stevie yeah
this is my dog chewie and we're gonna
rename somebody's dog no his real name
is that that's his original name yeah
chewie for short great schubert
yorkshire
how can you have you guys seen the thing
with the dogs talking
they're hitting the buttons and talking
to their owners oh i saw that on youtube
huge and it's real it's real thing so
like they train them where like so they
have a button like this button and then
when the dog paused the button like say
one of them is like treat treat or i'm
hungry and it says treat and so then you
give them you train them by giving them
a treat and then you you make them press
another button for pet and then you pet
them every time they do it and then
voice recognition yeah technology and
then they like they go boom boom boom
boom and then they start to like so this
dog was talking to its owner like
outside
you know something something danger
boom and then like please send help
nobody was like yeah
the girl had a thing where the dog uh
had a splinter
and the dog basically let the the the
owner know something's wrong with me
you know what i mean and then she
figured it out that's nuts dogs like
blue balls blue balls
blue yeah that's the one i saw the dogs
would be like where are my balls
yeah you took my balls you evil [ __ ]
[ __ ]
okay let's not let's not look at this uh
did weren't they doing that with
dolphins we met i thought dolphins for a
while were doing that [ __ ] they're
pretty smart oh yeah they're hiding shut
the [ __ ] up dolphins it's funny if you
got like a really racist dog or
something like he's just or he's just
sexist you'd be like i knew i'd be like
i knew it
i
[Applause]
[Laughter]
but it was pretty amazing though
honestly and this is it yeah
[Music]
yeah there it is there's yeah there you
go holy [ __ ]
there's a big barge going by guess what
i'm saying it's amazing bunny has been
using
buttons to communicate with me since she
was eight weeks old
[Music]
oh wow that's insane right you don't
think he's mistaken no no man because
it's certain things man
that's a bird
[Music]
so so they're talking about this
technology
they're talking about this technology
being able to use to like
get to a point where a dog can let you
know where it's hurting or something
damn it because that would be like you
know when things happen with dogs they
don't know that's the tough part about
women never know they have to just
assume and kind of guess and you don't
know what's going on you know with
babies too right yeah no idea what's
going on no one sees no idea what's
going on so this is like a really
amazing like this is a weird crossover
you've seen the ricky morty episode
where rick designs that thing so the dog
can talk
and then they give it a battery pack and
then the dog starts his like it helps
his brain out next you know the dog's
just like in a full robot outfit he's
like you took my ball
do you think i want that yeah he's late
in the middle of now he just walks up as
a robot he's like who cut off my balls
she's like what
that would be the first thing any dog
would say hell yeah they'd be like well
you weren't [ __ ] everybody
your red rock was all over the place but
now they take they what they do for the
dog so it doesn't feel like they're
missing their balls but i'm who knows
they need to talk to a dog who can talk
they put in the the fake plastic balls
so it looks like they still have nuts
yeah but that's not what it's not a
cosmetic thing no the dog's like what
the [ __ ] dogs like i got two implants
yeah are they like
jelly bean like how big are the balls i
think you can pick like titties like
double d's okay they're like like
ping-pong balls
right
those bulldogs have some nuts on them
bro see look at that no dude see that's
a big nut dude
what's a face what is just making me
feel bad about ping pong who gave the
dog that long a little pebble on the
right
like sam casella in the playoffs
oh they blur that out
that's his one ball well he was just he
was just cause he hit a big shot so he's
like i got big cajones oh damn he's got
a big ball dude
this guy had a dog-related king at her
stinger for us all right well
yeah got a king of the stinging for you
guys
bringing your dog to the workplace is it
fun or is it annoying as hell if you get
a shitty dog there let me know
well i mean he he already said he he
already laced the question with what we
all think anyways like if you have a
shitty dog correct if it's a bad dog
like pissing on the walls yeah it
depends on the work too like chewie's
just this is what chewie does chewie's
fine you can bring chewy whenever but if
it was like chewing on the couch
or we're all scared you bring a [ __ ]
pitbull in or some [ __ ] everyone's all
scared of them i was a hypocrite too
because i was like keep your dog at home
they're fine i hated people who said
their their dogs have anxiety but chewie
really has anxiety and he has to come
with me he does
he comes from a rough background yeah
when i first ever went on the road my
first road gig was uh i was working for
tribble the triple runs this guy dave
tribbled out of montana so i had to fly
to utah
and in the in the headliner we got in
his car and he brought a boxer
that's not good that's a small dog yeah
it's a boxer so we drove all over in
montana with this box sweet dog but
boxers have huge anxiety man and and
they're active oh like they want to play
well all of them you're generalizing now
all boxers are all bad they're known for
having a lot of i used to have one but
they're called the comedians of dogs
though yeah because they're silly or
whatever yeah they just they create they
they do they're goofy as hell yeah and
they're boxers because they do box
they'll come and hit you in your face
but they love kids and they'll just be
like you know but it's like it's it's to
me it's a lot i'm not a fan of dogs i'm
not a fan of just dropping a dog on
somebody with no notice no i don't like
that no
one time uh we had a scare at the house
this is years i'm five years ago we had
a scare at the house where someone broke
in
and i was like oh we need i freaked out
because i was going to australia on tour
so i was leaving my family for two weeks
right so i was like we gotta do
something we got guns and that one
called my boy who's like in the special
forces he's like bro you just need a
malinois he's like i'll get take care of
it for you so my cool where's it at it's
like northern california i drive up
there i get this dog i talk to the train
like now this dog only speaks german if
you say something else it's gonna be
it's gonna have problems i'm out no i
was like hell yeah all right but my
girl's never owned a dog before so i
dropped this [ __ ] zero dark 30 dog at
the house how big was it [ __ ] big
dude only speaks german but just a
straight killer bigger than my girl's
never had a dog doesn't like dogs and
i'm like no he's gonna protect you while
i'm gone how does a dog know you can't
just drop a oh i'm an idiot i'm a
[ __ ] idiot so you came back your
family was broke no i i fly i fly to
australia right and i have like a
thousand missed calls from my girl so i
listen to the voicemail and you just
hear row row she's like hey help help
it's marking the kick oh my god oh of
course yeah
what did you hear my girl being like
don't stack up
i'm like that was a bad idea and that's
my fault that's my fault you just
dropped hitler off at your house oh bro
he was [ __ ] jacked what'd you end up
doing with the dog like i kept him for a
long time after that and then i gave
them to a police sergeant that lives
close to me so i still see the dog all
the time
yeah
that i [ __ ] up man yeah
i panicked that dog was not you gotta do
some research next time man yeah you
gotta meet the dog
he make like an alligator moat you know
just be like okay good luck everybody if
you like can you just
have a wild ass beast drop off at your
house oh this thing was such a savage
yeah it only spoke german if you gave it
the wrong command it was [ __ ] on man
yeah my girl's like this i've never
owned a dog before though i'm like well
and they probably the dog probably
picked up on everybody's fear oh that
was a thing their dog was like alpha in
that house give me some food [ __ ] yeah
you know yeah
did it bite
uh it when it got excited and just like
nibbled at my son and my girl didn't
know dogs she like freaked out i have a
picture of tiger in the in the [ __ ]
schnauzer dog that just that beast of a
[ __ ] navy seal dog and they're both
laying on the ground my son's like
staring them like this in the picture
yeah yeah
i like um you know like
i think pit bulls get a bad rap i love
people they're loving they're actually
very great they're great humans like
they can be a little dog aggressive but
with humans there's not a better dog
yeah i've seen i love seeing like a
picture of like a little baby and then
two giant people
or you see the baby sleeping like the
people like guards the baby yeah man so
it's like i think pitbull is like i want
to get a dog but my girl's like what'd
you say people at the um shelter man
what does that have to do with being
poor i'm getting a fresh new dog okay oh
if your girlfriend's allergic to you
like golden doodle and stuff where
they're not looking for yeah i think i
think a rottweiler's uh no they shed
don't they no i think they're like
golden doodles well i looked up the uh
thing i looked up the hyper eyeball
allergenic yeah dogs and i think
rottweiler is one of them i hope it is
that's why i want a rottweiler i think
if you go to the right breeder they can
make hyperallergenic most things but
yeah yeah you should save a dog save one
oh here we go don't go to a breeder
save a dog
and if you do save a dog that's the
first thing so i want to tell you when
we get to the dog park it's a rescue
yeah [ __ ] what else you do yoga
this guy this is my i made good life
choices dog yeah yeah
this guy also he wanted to shout out his
dog's name's kuma and he's a coach at
bill algios mma gym in pennsylvania i
knew something was up because he's like
uh keith's thing bringing dogs to work
with this guy right here yeah yeah yeah
he looks like mma guy huh yeah
check the ears or the shirt yeah it
looks like an mma shirt
all right next one you guys never king
did or stinged it
he kind of said it though it's like a
shitty dog trying to stick to protocol
what else is weird yeah i appreciate you
sticking to those so what is it you're
king in it yeah i know you're kidding me
yeah yeah king it yeah depending
on if it's a good dog but i'll sting any
animal on the plane remember for the
longest time finally the the tsa was
like hey but quit bringing your goddamn
golden retriever on the plane well any
ostriches some [ __ ] came out with a
turkey yeah but they have those but they
have those uh
they have those like oh these is a
doctor's note yeah this is my you know
comfort comfort turkey yep or whatever
it is like that yeah somebody's really
trying to bring on a big-ass turkey
that's crazy we should have like a
comfort
extra girlfriend you know
you're like i just get a doctor's note
whatever your doctor's note is like you
need a side piece
deal bro
bro
dude let me know girl like what the
doctor like doctor said you know what he
said that's going to actually help our
relationship i'm just kidding rachel
case you're watching
i'm not it's a brilliant idea
if there's a doctor out there right you
know we're lying brandon yeah yeah yeah
somebody bought a [ __ ] live dinosaur
on the plane
what up cats
in a tiny apartment in southern
california two college dropouts teamed
up to create a watch company that broke
all the rules
with fair prices unexpected colors and
clean
original designs mvmt
that's right movement
grew into one of the fastest growing
watch brands shipping to over 160
countries around the globe
now that's a brand you can get behind
one that started
at grassroots
now mvmt is expanded in a blue light
glasses that protect your eyes from your
screens minimalist jewelry and more
style essentials that don't break the
bank all designed out of their
california headquarters yep
if you haven't tried a movement watch
then
you just
you ain't spending your time
wisely that's right movement watches
have the look and quality of a 400 to
500 watch
but cost a fraction of the price
that's where we live nowadays
stay hyped look hype the look is what
matters when it comes to this sort of
thing if you want to elevate your style
without breaking the bank
then join the movement get 15 off with
free shipping and free returns by going
to mvmt.com
kats
again that's mvmt.com
cats
football is right around the corner yep
you know it cats kitty cats football is
right around the corner it's coming you
can hear the football coming it's
rolling around the bin head to
draftkings sportsbook app now
and place about a one dollar or more on
any week one game to receive two hundred
dollars in free bets instantly that's it
that's right
nothing adds to the excitement of
watching a game quite like having a free
shot at a million dollar top prize a
million
download the draftking sports book app
now
use promo code cats to receive 200 in
free bets when you place a one dollar
bet on any football game
and get a free shot at a million
top prize with your first deposit that's
promo code kats for a limited time only
at draftking sportsbook and official
sports betting partner of the nfl must
be 21 or older new jersey indianapolis
or pa only new customers only minimum
five deposit and one dollar wager one
per customer restrictions apply c
draftkings.com sports book for details
gambling problem call one eight hundred
gambler or in indiana one eight hundred
nine with it
i'm about to find that doctor give me a
[ __ ] hall pass for a side piece like
yeah they said for my mental health
i need a girl with a blowout ass
a what ass a blowout
hey are we going to do that that that
ceremony send off yeah we got to do it
yeah we'll put it next week we'll do it
before the show and we'll play it on
there i could bring my butt of course
yeah bring the butts always welcome
oh we'll put it right there in the
middle of the table bro can we bring we
have to bring gloves just put in the
ziplock bag i want you to know he's been
in it yeah be kind of weird
eric really think about what you're
about to say watch your words just watch
your words that's all
watch your words and now here's the
thing stevie you know it's going away
next week so that butt's like here we go
talk about it hold on it's sanitized
when's the last time you gave me the
thorough
put it in a ziploc bag right
you can pretend that that fake ass
doesn't have covered and you're bringing
it in here
bro ask me again now i now i'll have a
visual of steve in the shower with the
butt and he's just got it like wait like
a football he's got like shampoo and
he's going like that
i'll dab it dude you i'll soap it up
dude uh i respect you guys i'll do it
for you guys
yeah
so i'll i'll wash it with shampoo and
soap okay yeah and then i'll put it in a
ziploc bag hannick and we'll bring
hazmat suits for everyone you don't have
to do that it's going to be clean
it's going to trick it's going to
trigger theo if he sees that ass but me
and eric are cool well i'll put in a
shoebox right and we could have flowers
in this shoebox how big is it that ain't
a big enough ass fitting in the shoe box
my man it's pretty big dude
you're getting a briefcase steve's butt
and the way he also measures dicks is
the same thing
it's all the same it's like this is a
fat ass double whopper yeah no i was
referring to theo being that
but the point are you guys thinking this
is the black box word around town is he
is it's got the biggest penis in the
comic community
brandon give him some love there
i'm sure i'm sure he's packing some but
big
there's some big dicks out there man
[Laughter]
i didn't know that i didn't know there
was a website for this yeah i've heard
him say he's got that short round
okay i'll bring it next week all right
okay no problem this guy's got a king
understand it
what's going on brandon and theo or
brandon and stevie or brandon and
griffin man i can't keep track anymore
hey me neither either
i'm exhausted
go ahead y'all keep changing co-hosts as
much as most people change their
underwear
but anyway i got a king and a stinger
for you i think jake paul should start
his own fighting league what do you
think me personally i think a lot of
fighters will jump ship and go over to
his league especially if he's paying as
well as he paid anthony taylor for
sparring
he's like the modern day robin hood he's
stealing the money out of big daddy
donald's pockets and giving them to the
fighters
me personally i think a little
competition's healthy let me know what
you think
oh jake paul if you see this and you
like my idea i like 10 percent bro i got
a lot of mouths to feed gang gang buzz
buzz
he was like i wonder how many times it
took him
to film that
he could probably
rehearse
that was taken
yeah
his wife said calm down calm down it's
just a show it's a comedy show babe
how'd you know that dude it's just you
can tell it doesn't feel like his word
yeah it doesn't feel natural you know
you sound it sounds like you did that 20
times because he's not enthused yeah
yeah yeah yeah
all right fellas
or is he he's reading enough cue cards
or something no he didn't know that no
well in terms of this jake paul thing
first of all let's review the fight by
the way well i didn't see the fight oh
you didn't see you saw it i saw the
recap so you didn't see it either yeah
i saw the replay but would you would you
in the region i saw i saw tyrone he
landed a big shot
shot against the ropes he almost downed
him yep um
i don't know i mean i'm not into
fighting i just i just it's too violent
i just don't like the violence of it and
you know and i just always think of
muhammad ali and how he was in his later
life yeah just yeah and even like that
takes the fun even like evander
holyfield even like all these guys all
these fighters you see them and how they
talk and what's going on now they're
using the buttons the dogs yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
like [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
there's there needs to be weight classes
though wouldn't you agree i mean he
looks so much bigger uh he's gonna have
like thirty three weight classes but
here's the thing with jake paul in his
own fight league
so you know he he he paid those other
fighters good there's a reason i mean
dana could pay the fighters more but
when you get into making the sausage and
you go through the numbers
it's going to be a beast man like i know
he wants to pay everyone you know fairly
and stuff like that but once you really
get into it in the the production and
renting the arenas and then you realize
oh damn this could start taking out my
pocket he's me singing a different tune
what does it have to do with weight
classes though i mean they have weight
classes though but he was a way bigger
guy than tyrone woodley yeah but that's
uh he had like 40 pounds on him i know
but that's like it's an exhibition he
had some pounds on that exhibition but
yeah it wasn't a real fight in sense of
like and he's making that kind of paper
doing that okay well this is my point
i'm trying to he made millions dude i
don't know yeah because people bought it
though stevie that like that's the
that's his market exhibition about but
against a guy who has a lot more
experience like his advantage who has
more experience woodland not even close
yeah but he can do takedowns or jiu
jitsu or even in boxing but just in
fighting general he has you know i don't
know ten times i just think the win has
a it's a big deal i know but it's an
exhibition about yeah if he goes into
more professional fighting it's going to
be waking up so if he has 125 pounds and
the guy's 200 pounds and it's an
exhibition is that fair you know
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter because if it was a pro
fight in this 12 rounds they're not
going to let that fly yeah yeah yeah how
many rows eight it was eight rounds
eight rounds yeah all right
they had to weigh in the same weight
okay they had to they did they both
weighed in 190. they did yeah yeah okay
i didn't know so jake's just taller
that's probably bigger though too dude
he's way bigger i mean he's bigger for
sure but they both he's cutting weight
but that happens in the ufc stevie like
yeah there's certain guys that you know
if they cut to like uh darren till you
still fight at 170. what did he cut what
do you cut down from i always wondered
by 210. he cut that
so is that all water weight like because
i used to wrestle we used to there's a
lot of water but there's a lot to it
like anthony johnson rumble johnson used
fight 170 walked around 220 230.
that's insane that's one of the craziest
ways
yeah is there a method to the madness
yeah so they i mean but but sometimes
like guys who cut a ton of weight then
they don't perform like it's too much
weight and they feel like [ __ ] and i
really believe in like being dehydrated
you're more likely to get knocked out
because 100 percent fluid is your brain
100 uh yeah i don't think it's good but
it's hard to get rid of there's no real
reason well i think that i think that
what all these fighters should take from
jake paul is being your own brand yeah
and i think that that is the thing that
we're moving towards because what logan
and jake have done you know they've
taken their they they i think that
they're very serious about fighting and
they take it very seriously but the
thing they also take seriously is their
marketing
marketing themselves yep and that's what
he did and it's like all these guys
should have social media
and this is the new age like you look at
the nba players like zion williams for
instance yeah i was following him when
he was in high school long before yeah
he had two three million followers going
in the comments and you don't care that
he plays for the pelicans you don't care
about zion like you know you hit it
right in the nose like for for jake and
logan it's like they could fight on
trailer they can find showtime hbo the
ufc
it doesn't matter these guys i care
about jake and lisa it's not and this is
a new era of media it's not just about
it's not just about skill it's not just
you know and this goes for all
professions it's the same thing that's
happening in the comedy profession you
know man it's like what you talking
about is somebody being like this guy's
super funny but like people don't know
him they can't access them they don't
know anything about him or he's not
relatable not relatable
for whatever reason it doesn't connect
but he's a monster on stage yeah but it
doesn't even matter somebody like you
know you do you have like are you in a
podcast or are you like what's your
social media presence are you doing
videos are you on tick tock and all the
cuz how are people going to find out
you're performing
it's just a new era so it's like these
all these people in the fighting world
they're messing up they need to be doing
like daily like hey i'm training or i'm
like whatever it is and then people will
be like oh i like that guy you know
who's doing that is is he style bender
like could do a breakdown of the jake
paul fight he'll do a recap of it he'd
do like lifestyle stuff yeah man and
then you look at the views and like when
he retires he's gonna have that to fall
back on that's what i'm saying what
about the comic that has the fan base
and the branding but he's not as funnier
as the guy
you know that's super funny at least it
matters
i think it matters a little bit there
because no there's a minimum there won't
be there will be longevity you know what
i'm saying see i don't know i don't know
about that i think there's a first of
all there's a minimum standard like the
people aren't dumb you know what i mean
like so you have like you know you have
like your comics comic or let's say like
you have somebody that like comics find
funny or you have some artsy fartsy type
we hear that all the time it's the
comics yeah it just means that the
comics appreciate the joke structure
they appreciate how the the delivery and
all that stuff so there's some minimum
standard of like where
the person is still likable and
relatable to their fans
uh and that's all that really matters
that's what we're finding out because
before we just relied on hollywood to
tell us all right who gets a power who
gets to do what who you should pay
attention and then people like andrew
schultz oh he dictates that andrew
schultz was like ah [ __ ] y'all you don't
want to oh he went around the system
because they weren't giving them they
weren't passed to the castle and they
were like don't you need representation
when you get to that level don't you
need like representation or be a part of
she has but he's not gonna like he
doesn't do anything to entertain
hollywood like before guys like i don't
know if i'd say this joke man he does
whatever he wants whatever you want you
got to respect that i mean well that's
that's what attracts fans yeah fans hate
that hollywood [ __ ] now they do yeah
they don't dig it anymore well there's
so many because now you have direct to
consumer that's what i'm saying direct
to consumer so now like you know the the
the like for instance the ufc is
controlled by one person
so you so you need that person you know
you need that person right you have to
have that to play that game but jake
paul and these people might they might
be like no i don't think we need him yep
i don't think we need him
did that too right didn't conor do his
own thing no he came up with ufc then
partnered with ufc oh he didn't do his
own league or anything oh so you're
saying do your own league if you have
i'm saying you don't even need a league
all you need is a a network that's going
to say and a fan base and a fan base and
that's it yeah that's all you need what
do you need any like organization for if
you're bringing all the fans like you
know it could be like a street fighter
fall you want if jake paul was like yeah
live on youtube backyard brawl yeah or
something
boom boom and it cost five dollars to
watch people would show up but that's
what i'm saying is that we rely so much
on like these establishments but that's
what we learned in the pandemic too is
that these places are just buildings and
people could do their own thing you know
like you know they started that
supernova show
and outside outside it's still going
strong
you know so i'm saying people are
realizing hey you know what we can
actually do shows wherever wherever the
talent is people are going to come
and so i think it just goes for all
these types of things too i think boxing
comedy entertainment
whatever it might be you know but like
this i mean look look at rogan yeah i
was like i'm gonna pack my shop go to
austin just build my own club there
that's what i'm saying we didn't king or
sting though that thing
oh i think
these fighters should take a lesson like
even if you hate the guy he's getting
all this attention he didn't pay his
dues i get it but the takeaway should be
oh i need to market myself yeah market
yourself
perfectly like even if you hate the guy
the one you can't take is you got to own
your own [ __ ] your own brand your merch
brand becomes undeniable yeah man
because it's like even if like even if
you're not like you know it's not it's
not a meritocracy in in in this business
in these businesses anymore it's not
just about the best is going to be here
you know they'll get to because they're
not even getting the opportunity to
prove who's the best i've always said
that the fighting should work more like
traditional sports in a sense that you
should have a season
it should be like some sort of like
brackets or something it should be some
sort of point base that so we know in
nine months
would these two people fight we know
they're the best fighters in the world
yeah there's no there's no determination
now like it has turned over to kind of
entertainment too like if you're if you
become champ you know your champ
everybody knows you're the best but like
there's a guy like leon edwards who's
won like nine in a row from england is
yeah he's a badass he's a badass which
is not very marketable to the american
fan base yeah because he's there so he
doesn't give him a title shot and the
the fans like come on dude yeah
if he's like
that's not fair because like in fighting
that's kind of different than comedy
because
but when you're a good fighter and
you're kicking everyone's ass you can't
deny that they are denying it they are
just but it's the same as on stage like
we just said they're what we're saying
they're not giving him a copy that's not
fair i mean in fighting that's not fair
i could see in comedy let me ask you
this stevie if you owned the comedy
store or you owned the ufc who said you
want to make it
who's putting butts in seats
like how many
comics are monsters are so talented yeah
if you were him though what would you do
different though that's a better
approach if i was dana no no the the
fighter uh edwards it's what it's what
he's starting a podcast with these yeah
he's got to do
dude he's there
he's in london hey guys it's my youtube
channel but that's not yeah it's his
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
if that's not
i think there's two routes
win until you're undeniable which he's
not doing because he's refusing to not
fight unless it's a title shot basically
he's turned down all these fights or do
what you said build your brand where
they want you to fight yeah because
yeah and also there's a shelf life to
fighting man
you can't just be like i'm gonna wait
till i get my shot then some you know 21
year old kid is going to be like i'm
about to beat y'all yeah oh you know
yeah let's do this
what's his name ian edwards
oh leon
though leon edwards
is fighting leon edwards if you're
watching king of the sting what about
for one episode
he sits in eric's seat and that will
give him a platform here's the thing to
sell him here's the prom stevie is we're
in the business of entertainment and
comedy that's not his forte he's got
he's a funny guy isn't he
no and you can't even understand him
you know what i'm saying like ian's a
monster yeah it's a monster i'm talking
about
yeah give me give liana shot what about
a 20-minute segment where he sits there
and you could do that for him man
you have the power
i appreciate you this ain't make a wish
bubba like he's gonna have to figure it
out you know and say like i love the guy
so leon if you're out there i'm a comedy
route might not be for leon edwards yeah
yeah but does he have to be funny yes
this is a comment you should be like
that's why he's that's why you could
just say he should market himself yeah
that's all we're saying so what does he
have to do take improv lessons i'm
confused like he just hey man i don't
know you know
talk to his manager that's right staying
up to date on the latest trends and
and with football coming on and and with
school starting back there's a lot of a
lot of reasons to eat and a lot of
things that are going to exhaust you and
make you hungry well grubhub's got you
covered yup grubhub works hard to serve
restaurants so they can work hard to
serve you
grubhub is right now doing a little
extra to serve panera get a free
delivery perk on your first order from
panera of 15 or more
order through the grub hub app or online
grub hub
we serve restaurants
for 50 years now american home shield
has protected household budgets from the
unexpected
like a dryer that won't dry or an ac
that won't turn on or that's lost its
cool
in fact
american home shield helps cover the
cost to repair or reduce parts of over
20 home systems and appliances when they
wear out no matter how old they are
service fees limitations and exclusions
apply see plan for details if american
home shield can't remit repair the
covered item they'll replace it yep
american home shield members get more
more coverage options and fewer
exclusions yep coverage available no
matter how old your systems and
appliances are exclusive fifty off for
listeners of this show right now to
celebrate 50 years of providing
homeowners peace of mind
you can take 50 off the most
comprehensive plans ever go to ahs.com
k-a-t-s now to save fifty dollars that's
ahs.com
k-a-t-s for fifty dollars off any plan
american home shield be sure with the
shield we've got another debate club for
you guys
what's up king instinct this is chris um
i love what you guys did with karaoke i
would love to hear more
um if you could play um any karaoke song
or do a karaoke song what would it be i
know eric has that soul
that's a riffing with griffin fans
um
let's hear what he had to say thanks bye
yeah so eric wasn't here a couple weeks
ago we did karaoke yeah dude without you
it'll be back it'll be back oh we got to
do it with him next week with eric
he would kill it but we need we can't
play the song the songs otherwise we'll
get flagged by youtube so it's chin's
going to learn the song so what what i
already got one i'm gonna hit it out the
ballpark what is it uh cindy lock cindy
lauper time time after time cindy why
are you whispering into a microphone
time after time cindy lopper time after
time dude
i'm going to practice all week i don't
think i've ever played that go ahead
guys
wow so you were a gangster and a
musician
i was not in the game are you the
soulful you soulful guy they were like
jim
sing that song like west side story
chill everything down
a talented guy
yeah
hey we're waiting we'll think of
something oh you figured out something
off top of your head go ahead eric next
week we i ordered a spinning wheel and
we're going to put all the options on
there and we're going to spin them and
whichever one you land on you're going
to have to sink so wow do you have one i
rocked out the metallica last time
metallica yeah yeah
i did more than words i don't know
he did enter salmon it was yeah i know
that guy the what's his name the more
than words uh extreme guy the guitarist
he doesn't go to the comedy store all
the time you know ben court you know ben
carter yeah yeah i know him well i got
his name
okay can i tell you a quick story about
him so he goes to the commie store all
the time and he's a weird hippie looking
dude right when he's at the commie store
so i didn't know this he comes up to me
and he's like a huge fan man
i'd love for you to can you come to my
50th birthday party and perform i don't
know this [ __ ] yeah i'm
weird-looking and i'm like oh man dude i
don't he's like you know what i'll email
you you know yeah so i get this really
nice email from like his assistant or
someone and i'm like okay the way it was
written and they're gonna pay me perfect
i'm like i'm like okay you know what
they came at me right i'll go i start
driving i'm in the hollywood hills yo
and i'm going up
and up big boys and up yep and up past
the hollywood sign get up and i'm like
oh [ __ ] get to the house it's beautiful
mansion mansion dude i go inside
they say just wait in there he's coming
this the wall is filled with gold
records
and then he comes out in a dope ass suit
looking like a [ __ ] you know what i
mean yeah and i was like he was like and
i look i go more than words i go hey man
open with this
i was scared
open with this [ __ ]
i thought it would be playing an
apartment in north hollywood
he said he was his 50th birthday his
chick was 24. yeah you know what i mean
her mom was there too just looking like
she was thinking
yeah her mom was like
this should be me
but he's such a cool dude that's dope
and he's actually like he was like
rihanna's music musical director oh [ __ ]
yeah he's like
yeah he's a yeah he's like a you know
but he had this beautiful house and you
would never think it i would never even
think so obviously don't judge a book by
his cover like wait to see how somebody
approaches you and comes out where do
you make that money that's one song
that's like one popular what are the
other songs steve back in the day
oh he's just metallica extreme
extreme there's more than words more
than words guy yeah but steve back in
that day you can make a lot of money on
one song i remember mtv seeing the music
videos but also produces a lot of stuff
yeah it produces all ghost writing and
stuff like that all right right right i
just know that he he yeah he has a lot
of areas yeah so how much was the gig
it was good enough for me to like drive
up to the hills to some stranger's house
comedy in front of strangers it was fine
i should have asked for more actually
[Laughter]
so no song in your back pocket that you
guys yeah go ahead brandon
mine would be what would you do by city
high
it's you guys will know it if you hear
it what would you do if your something's
at home uh you're not alone on the bus
oh
there you go
yeah i have a lot of i'm one of those
guys that has a karaoke list
or yeah when i go to karaoke i'm like
it's good to be back everybody it's
gonna be bad no eric's the guy just no
no come on i can't get
that i'm not going to sing that again
stop dying come on this isn't my thing
give me that
throw give us a name i like ray charles
i like uh uh what's the one um um um i
wanna i'm drawing a blank right now
stevie wonder then i don't like no no no
i don't do any stevie stevie winter
songs are really hard to sing prince uh
i like i'm a pr i like prince i'm a
purple rain guy
sing purple ring i'm uh let's see what
else um i got chocolate uh kissing a
fool george michael that's my go-to jam
right there you look that one up that's
the jam gin how hard would it jazz for
you to play some dave matthews like
satellite how dare you no no dave matt
one thing i can't
do
don't don't don't do that oh really
it's really really awkward and it's
constantly rotating
oh wow
yeah super hard
wasn't hendrix didn't hendricks play his
guitar in a weird way left-handed you
know wow what about john mayer
michael but if i have to learn all these
songs it's going to be pretty tough in
one week we'll whittle it down we'll
whittle it down you'll figure but i mean
i think worst case we can do karaoke
tracks because karaoke tracks they'd
always get picked up on copyright
with the instrumentals of them
actually they do sometimes sometimes
they'll flag it on youtube yes because i
because i used to because i used to do
this where i would game
and in between my gaming i would do sing
karaoke songs
on youtube yeah they'll be like this is
copyright song when i got you a gig when
i actually first started doing my
podcast i was like i'm trying to come up
with a theme song and what i would do is
like play
like that's the karaoke of a song and
then like just make up the words
and i got flagged oh wow so then i was
like well
then the monetizing goes to
whoever publishing yeah they don't they
don't you know yeah they give all their
your money a lot of times they share
though a lot of times
that's not a good chance
how about if i bring a little purple
ring thing and i'll just do the beats
yeah purple rain purple ring
purple rings yeah
you got to have the
the what do you call it you guys have
the mic effects that's what makes it
that's what makes karaoke work i have
one little
thingy first you do yeah
go ahead chin our household has it
sorry man okay yeah most households that
i know i don't have it yeah well because
i have the rice cooker there's no space
you know
where you gonna put the karaoke machine
next to the xbox
one my black button i'm not that much
you're smelling my black butt
your nose
what's this guy want nick
this guy's got another fake club for us
what up king in the sting family matt
here sending y'all a whole lot of love
from
new york city i know y'all holding down
out west i got you out east um shout out
to everybody in the studio brendan eric
stevie jesus y'all are like the junior
varsity united nations that just gave up
on trying but i've got a debate club for
you i don't know if you've heard about
the bishop's high school football
scandal and i'm sure nick could give you
any sort of context if you haven't but
here's my question what is more
embarrassing losing 58 to zero on
national tv or espn airing a football
game with a fake high school espn it's
absolutely absurd you heard that right
what do you think gang gang buzz buzz
stay blessed and brenden if you ever
come out east and need a spotter you
gotta be too something to do something
baby holla at your boy what's up dog
damn he rich rich yours you're that crib
new york yeah he was that was the set of
friends that was kind of flossy right
yeah yeah
he just showed up
right there he does he does video
tutorials
i wonder if he rented out an influencer
space or something there's a ring light
back there that's what i'm saying
so what does he know what is this about
have you seen this so espn aired this
game against was it img uh which is like
a real big like national powerhouse high
school right and they couldn't find
their opponent they couldn't find
opponent for months months so they
reached out to a third party to find an
opponent well this third party is like a
scam
and they filled it with this high school
that's like actors well they said well
we got like ten five star recruits and
he has planned to do any due diligence
and just let this team play him and
they're like fake fake players one dude
graduating like 1999.
they just got their ass beat beat and
just it's it's it's like joe's versus
pros like you like what how the [ __ ] did
you why would you let that happen and
nobody nobody looked into it so you see
these coaches just super unprofessional
on the sidelines they're trying to with
other teams man there is but they were
just trying to find a
a team to play this monster team i think
it had to do with like other powerhouses
didn't want to play this team because
then you get a loss on your record
this is like the team well that's just
like fighting well look at that they
look like they're [ __ ] down espn
that's that's the legit this is the
legit thing not the espn and the
announcers started like a basically
apologizing yeah the announcers knew
they're like yeah play playing the next
one prospects that's just
is that the make-believe team
no that's the real that's the real team
also the dallas cowboys wait the real
team beat the fake team yeah get the
[ __ ] out of them oh i thought the fake
team no hell no no the victim was full
of like non-football players
guys who graduated like 97.
and their names are super fake
and whoever said they were in charge of
the fake school got like a big check but
now there's lawsuits all over but these
announcers kind of because announcers
worry because this team beat them so bad
like you know was just a health concern
at this point man because guys lose the
score
53-0 oops it had a number of division
one prospects
on their roster
to be frank a lot of that we could not
verify
database they did not show up
in the databases of other recruiting
services so it's okay that's what you're
telling us fine that's how we take it in
from what we've seen so far that this is
not a fair fight and
there's
these people on the sidelines that's the
fake team
i already i'm worried about it i want to
see one play yeah go ahead go ahead this
is this could potentially be they could
have beat him 200
given the circumstances and the mismatch
that we have here
and um and and quite honestly bishop
sycamore doesn't have not only the
frontline players but they don't have
the depth in case something were to
happen to their roster with maybe a kid
or two here throughout the remaining two
and a half years you know what's the
problem
yeah well i'll tell you how this happens
it's all about money man yeah they
didn't want to risk losing advertising
in the game it's like money money money
money money yeah the names of the
players they said who let this slide the
name of the players it's just a bunch of
there's multiple same names on there and
[ __ ] is the game online i want to watch
it
you do not it is not
entertaining man no they beat the [ __ ]
um
that's the names there ej wash jalen
knight
johnny melvin marcus
and then marquez goodwin is an nfl
player duncanson i like ej wash
mark armand
well devonta richards sounds like a good
player caldron foster
wow it's like the fake rookies in madden
when you do it yeah so what's the
incentive in this look at the depth
chart so do they get paid these guys
what was the incentive the the yeah
third party gets paid but what about so
they're just didn't get nothing no and i
wonder what notoriety but i wonder what
he told them
like what did he tell this team that he
got together like they had to know
like you didn't you didn't go in being
like oh we're playing a high school team
like they had to know that this is what
was happening yeah i don't know so they
so those guys on the sideline got paid
some money and they probably didn't even
realize they they got got you for sure
they probably were like looking at this
later like wait a minute i only got paid
500 for the day or whatever you know
whatever it is
it's hilarious though
because that high school the high school
what's the other example then so there's
that example what's the other one he
said what's more embarrassing losing 58
to zero or espn airing to facebook espn
yeah that's the most yeah that was
embarrassing but who's that embarrassing
too though is it because
yes the best is the announcers because
they got duped too because they thought
it was gonna be a competitive game
because yeah i'm sure they didn't do
their due diligence and they get they're
like who the [ __ ] is this team well if
you're especially if they're announcers
or like x football players guys because
it's like when you're watching a fight
i'm sure that if there was some amateur
you would just notice it like like this
oh you'd be like oh that guy doesn't
know what he's doing even though the
layman would be like i don't know what
you're talking about it's like you know
when you watch gymnastics and then like
uh you know you hear the person being
like ooh that that was yeah yeah i
thought it was pretty good and i'm like
i look great
about it
you're a 10.
so that's probably what these guys
instantly were like you know what the
toughest thing to tell in the olympics
is that when they dive the olympic
divers when they do all the flips i'm
like
it looks fine
they all look like tens yeah
i think it was the worst team like in
the history of diving so they might as
well send the lee brothers
check it out
in singapore and right now the
philippine diving team
nobody else's face is like but he knew
he listen man let me tell you something
when he hit that dog in his brother hell
yeah
where's that all right show them the
other one that you're most difficult
this guy's the best holy spirit they
know they're about to eat [ __ ]
this is crazy like
in this face what am i doing here
why am i here
well that's like me jumping the [ __ ]
bull man
he got no height on that jumper no you
just did like a camera
yeah
they're like come on
this is the bishop sycamore diving team
yeah
but that's that's who the filipino scent
to represent them man these guys are
like we'll try bro we gotta get these
guys on the show i love this game
it looks like that's their first time
ever diving like they told them when
they got there so this is their team no
that's what we've got the best filipino
this is the best dude this is the best
imagine who finished fifth and didn't
get getting qualified
that [ __ ] broke their head on i
love they gone the splash brothers
are these the only guys who showed up
for this yeah
for trials it's like they showed up they
missed the first day of practice but
then they started showing up they missed
the diving part but they're talks and
rolls yeah they're types and rolls the
dive is good dude i bet they went home
we're like mom you go the olympics do
that for what
the first one or this no no that that
first guy first guy's awake listen he
knew
when he did this movie hold up when
he's already making the face like the
other is analyzing here the thing is the
divers usually don't strain this heart
either in the face
okay let's see what he knew he was
really good okay
he's all [ __ ] [ __ ] right here he knew he
didn't do it right
i'm talking about because you like wait
wait till they show his face he knows
[Laughter]
he's not even in line with the board
[Laughter]
oh my god okay so i love that he tried
that was the first one
okay high five
zeros yeah those are zero you got zeros
zeros yes
this guy's like a [ __ ] i mean zero i
mean he come on man okay so that would
be like that'd be the thing that the uh
i mean like it looks like they're
surprising there's a lot of warriors and
be like
that's racism here we go
no they they're slipping off the board
yeah and they're not they're going off
to the side and [ __ ] no he shouldn't be
under the diving both of the official
experiences
the second one was worse what's the
biggest flashlight
at the end
oh my god good call stevie
what else you got nick uh stevie i guess
took our talk about male only fans to
heart
and those cats in the wild yeah this is
a cats in the wild they're stevie
[Laughter]
[Music]
i look like
that
yeah yeah
me making sure i still got every five
minutes look at the face steve he just
has those hanes socks on
doesn't it hurt when people that's
supposed to be paid content now people
put it on the inside that's a dude
oh yeah it's probably dude gave you a
massage in the philippines yeah
okay guys
[Laughter]
next
this one has been sent in a lot recently
uh brendan joined the taliban oh god
look at this guy
oh wow oh wow
that's like my ass outfit though that's
like that guy is if brendan and aladdin
had a baby
[Laughter]
uh those were the best uh kingdoms
things of the week we got some good ones
for theo but we'll wait till he's back
that [ __ ] is funny man
oh man hey brandon hey theo have a king
or stinger for you this time airfryer
do you guys like them
do you guys use them brandon i know you
probably have somebody cooking for you
being all fancy theo
i know you're using that teflon pan for
everything
gang gang buzz buzz theo eats canned
food i don't know what it is
the air fryer is my family lives out
there what does that do what is this
[ __ ] is lit what is that you can like
cook chicken tenders like my kids eat
chicken tenders in like five minutes
they come out
what is that it's like a convection oven
i think uh they they had like a
renaissance over the pandemic because
you can put i got a convection oven it's
not an air fryer but i got a convection
i know they're great yeah they're great
but it's actually like it's just
enormous you can barbecue in there and
uh i don't know but my girl like does
wings they're the best chicken wings
you've ever done in your life it's
healthy because you're not cooking in
greece exactly it's white house how does
it heat up is it steamed like what is it
magic steve steve listen to the name
bear
fryer
air fryer
so frozen pizza yes chicken wings oh man
it's dope where can you get vegetables
target this sounds like one of those
like qvc commercials
so where can i get one of those yeah
no because that would fit in my
steve's gonna get rid of the hot plate
we gotta do a steve infomercial i can't
do everything can i
can i do everything with my air fryer a
chicken pot pie there's no way a chicken
pot pie is going to fit in there steve's
got to have the pigtails when he does
that
are we going to rest i can't do it i
can't actually put this whole turkey in
there can i and then like
i'm getting one oh they're dude
i'm getting one yeah target
and like if you could you can like
reheat like old pizza in there it stays
crispy steak that's my thing it's great
down my alley chicken wings dude my
girls chicken wings are ridiculous there
you go we did it brendan ceo ernie and
bird eyebrows thanks for having me on
king and the sting
uh my name is jordan i'm from the
seattle washington area i'm from a
little town called puyallup we got a
bunch of tribal stuff going on here and
with that we got a lot of casinos which
i'm actually at right now in the parking
lot
oh man i got a quick kinder stinget what
do you what's your guys take on casinos
do you like gambling are you not about
it if you do go to a casino what game
are you playing
for me personally i play blackjack but
that's because and let's keep this
little secret here i like to count cards
i'm learning how to do that
and i'm getting pretty successful at it
and i'm hoping to continue to do it in
the future
um so get that energy when you go to
vegas doug they will sniff you out and
[ __ ] first of all
i want to say already uh so this is a
sting on him yeah because
like it's not illegal to count cards
yeah because it's not illegal you're not
doing anything wrong but you the casino
will kick you out like this is a pretty
popular show all it takes is just one
person in the casino business to be like
well that guy's counting cards uh and
then they'll have they'll have them in a
system and there'll be some face
recognition yeah you're not getting he's
out you're not gonna get arrested but
the casinos just aren't gonna let you
know they're not gonna let you it's not
against the law i don't like playing
blackjack because i don't like being
around idiots
you don't know how to play no no no no
i'm saying if i'm at a table with people
and you know the dealer's showing a
three and you know you gotta you know
you got a six team you know you're
supposed to stay or like whatever you
know what i mean like there's a certain
there's a certain mathematical etiquette
it's dedicated so when you're not doing
that at a five at a five dollar table
i'm like nah man i'll give you five
dollars hit that you know what i mean
yeah because it's like i hate that so i
don't play unless i'm playing with my
friends yeah my game of choice is uh
craps oh craps i love crabs
yeah craps i don't like vegas yeah i
don't like magazines cool the weird the
pool's lukewarm it's filled with suntan
oil there's always hustles there's like
hustles too there there's so many
hustles they'll
it is what it is man you have some shows
yeah i was there all week and this is
why i can't stand in vegas don't bring
your kids to vegas it's not for kids
this ain't a kid's place no it's not
it's an adult playground you are selfish
when you are walking around a casino
with your six-year-old thinking you're
doing something you're there for you and
people are smoking yeah there's also
here there's also [ __ ] everywhere
there's that which is why we go
am i right
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm stamped
time
no reaction no man but the uh i don't
know man i just i i i like to gamble uh
but it can be a problem for people so
you know gamble oh yeah you know
correctly don't go with like it's an
addiction don't go yet don't go with
money that you need to pay your rent
roulette's fun too or the slots are fun
the slots are fun the slot machines are
fun see that's your asian coming out
yeah man coming up you're an old asian
woman only old asian women are at the
flat smoke chain so it's just like
chicken
smoking
dudes
are they territorial with the slot
machines come on steve you know this
the ants they all get together they take
up a section yeah
i don't like you they smoke in there i
don't like that
they vulture they wait for someone who's
been sitting there for a while to get up
like pissed off and then they said oh
they're super big they actually curb the
smoking though steve oh they did certain
yeah no we're not we're sure they're
vaping it's because it's because of the
uh they were like well we have to wear
masks right because you have to wear
masks at the thing now really yeah you
have to wear master they're like hey
and that and i'm with you on that like
if i'm if i have to wear a mask and some
[ __ ] is smoking like [ __ ] oh
oh okay hell no you know when times i
just fart at the table yeah
i swear to god somebody's just smoking
i'd just be
oh you don't like you don't like that
smell you don't like that i don't like
the cigarette is that smell bothering
you yeah is that is that obnoxious yeah
what's happening right now like get out
of here dude your farts would bother me
so bad dude
you're farts
steve yeah
did you take my tip hit up nba summer
league when you were there
i wanted to but it was just like listen
it was so hot oh it was [ __ ] you
don't want to do anything i don't i i
and then like i'm doing brad garrett's
club so where you stay and where the
club is is a legit 17-minute walk
okay every single time a hike you know
and then
is this is this club an mgm yes yeah and
then there's no room service oh no no
and in the signature towers there's
nothing there's you can't get water
there's nothing so you have to take this
walk so i i mean i was like nah i don't
i don't after all that i'm not going
outside what do you do there to pass
time then did you just stay in your room
right my xbox i was streaming all day
you're in new york this week right yeah
i'm going to caroline's because david
luke is going with you right yeah he's
he's already going to be out that's what
he said yeah so i was like i saw i i got
him on the show yeah that'd be great
yeah is it we're doing a comedy in las
vegas is it different it is way
different brendan isn't it different
it's all tourist how's it different how
is it different well but here's the
thing so if you're doing the strip it's
all tourist right yeah so unless you're
like seinfeld or leno that's not your
crowd it's all tourists but uh keith
from wise guys open the club
i uh hung out with paulie shore while i
was there yeah oh yeah he was the king
there it was he at wise guys uh no he
was gonna be but he's like you know
paulie's a weirdo yeah i mean so i love
him but he's like we did this like man
on the street thing with him
oh for his youtube chat for his youtube
for his instagram and people walking up
to him
because that was my because i'd always
do you know like uh casino theater show
like harris yeah like it was just weird
it's just a weird vibe i mean you have
your fan base with like a weird vibe and
then now that wise guy's opened in vegas
and it's in like it's it's for the
locals so i'm playing there i think
october what's wise guys wise guys is
like one of the best clubs in the nation
it's in salt lake city okay but he
opened a new one in vegas but it's for
the locals it's off the strip like in
the suburbs yeah that's why that's
different it's not off the strip it's
like it's just a little outside of it
yeah it's like because downtown's right
there yeah yeah because we went to this
barbecue place he took me to this
barbecue place that's right yeah down
the street from it but it's for but it's
for locals like it's not like if you
play the mirage or caesars or tourists
if you're if you're staying in vegas
you're not leaving your casino to go
down to something like you know you're
not doing that so that's got good food
there though at those casinos
and everything i don't like any of that
[ __ ] i don't like it i like a good
steakhouse me too i like a good
steakhouse but i ain't going to buffet
no okay i'm sorry i'm out at a buffet
listen why is everyone so ugly at the
buffet i was already
dude
because they think the tracks just
warlocked i
dude i was already iffy about buffets
before kovit like i when i would go to a
buffet i would be like i get like a
stack i say can you give me some hand
sanitizer things
every time i go to the thing i get the
food and then i go back to my table and
i wipe my hands you don't know what
people are doing oh bro i'll grab them
crab legs
oh they got crab lobster there toss it
back in and the next person picks it up
and says the kind of guy and then also
i'm not trying to [ __ ] my pants i'd get
like a piece of [ __ ] prime rib some
crab legs a [ __ ] sundae like you just
get all this weird [ __ ] have you ever
seen that have you ever seen a video of
the guy at whole foods
drinking eating the soup out of the
ladle what yeah have you seen that yes
that is dude no way he's not getting the
fire
a guy slurping soup at a buffet how
gross he was caught on camera slurping
what's your problem dude three
four times before
the ladle to the pot hole
disgusting
what world are you from oh dude that's
like etiquette right that's some buffet
stuff man agrees
because even at a buffet
sometimes i'm a people i'm a people
watcher oh me
so like so you'll see somebody at a
buffet get up and you know they just
went to the bathroom i don't know what's
going on in there i don't know what they
do in there they come back
you see them big girls the big white
girls grab the muffin look at it and put
the muffin back like [ __ ] you're fat
etiquette dude just grab the whole top
of my muffin yeah all right i don't like
buffets no more you shouldn't no also
think think how cheap that food is if oh
like the eggs as much as you walk in
you think that's like powdered eggs huh
it's not even probably have you ever
been on a cruise ship yeah dude i would
i remember my parents
carnival cruise ships right yep and
that's that that's just the ghetto
cruise it's the spirit airlines there's
three kinds of people on cruises you got
old you got fat
don't say asian and you got old well
old and fat and then asian
[Laughter]
no but they like and so like it's so bad
on cruise on the cruise ship that like
they have somebody administering the
bacon
what because otherwise it's people
otherwise just a free-for-all yeah wow
you know then you just wasted so the
guy's like you know what here's three
and then come back come back yeah you
need some more here's three and also
don't come back no but it was just so
that's what i'm saying it's like there's
something about buffet that's just like
i used to love buffets and then like as
i got older i was like i can't be doing
this a hometown buffet no never all
right all right cut that out
times the big one's golden corral right
now
but they're all going out of business
right supernatation went under golden
corrals not because i think jeff
foxworthy is like their spokesman people
don't want to do that i mean i that's
why i'm first person that's why i like
korean barbecue there you go because
you're touching it because like all you
have to worry about is they're bringing
the food okay and then you're burning
off all whatever it is yourself yeah
korean barbecue is great yeah korean
water best yeah so they're still open
which is good there's a maybe that one i
took you to over by my old place
delicious that place is great it's only
but they raised their price though used
to be 19. now it's 25. but i get it i
love cream you know what i mean people
got to make money side dishes all that
yeah i love all that stuff that's all we
got that's it all right kids uh
september 9th to the 11th i'm at san
jose improv santa san jose improv with
the boys chappelle lacy david our boy
david lucas that san jose improv 9th
through the 11th then after that i'm in
san antonio the big boy bud light event
center san antonio texas uh that's
september 24th one show september 25th
one show then i close out the end of
september in my hometown comedy works
denver come get your tickets at
fatkz.com or thickboy.com also the built
shirts uh collab with thick boy drops
next week today you can go see me in new
york i'll be at caroline's from the
second to the fourth great club and then
next week i'll be at the denver comedy
works from the 9th to the 11th and then
i finish september in boston
uh at the boston comedy club uh the 23rd
to the 25th nice so come check me out
phoebe scissor bros scissor bros at
austin texas sometime in september oh
moon tower comments that moon tower
festival nice man yeah that's right
appreciate guys
[Laughter]
[Music]
sponsor i am a monster about to open up
with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn hungry like i'm fresh off keto
seeing red like andrew santino every
song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso
hate on me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times they sliding into my dms a
couple of you tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz meaning
y'all edible just got my eyebrows
threaded and i'm feeling incredible
brandon son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]